hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for anime uproar and yami's little
sister was just revealed her insane
advanced conkers hockey meets kaoken
magic power was also revealed and she
straight up pimp smacked asta in front
of everyone we now know what asta's new
massive key power-up will look like and
the wano arc in black clover is off to a
crazy start so let's get into it you
guys know the drill if you enjoy our
content and you want to support it leave
a quick like and comment right now it
only takes a second but it really helps
with that youtube algorithm and of
course if you haven't already click that
subscribe button and hit the bell and
select the option that says all
subscribing is completely free but it
really helps us out on youtube finally
this video will contain black clover
manga spoilers so please proceed with
caution you have been warned so in the
previous chapter asta got isa kaiden to
yami's homeland called hino country
previously referred to as the land of
the rising sun so yeah just as those of
us who are fans of both one piece and
black clover thought that the wano arc
had finally ended we get to have another
wano arc but this time with asta asta
met yami's childhood friend ryu who just
happens to be the shogun of hino country
asta also met a girl who is the
subordinate of ryu and who was mean
mugging asta for some reason that
chapter raised a ton of questions some
of which were answered in this latest
chapter but there are still many other
lingering questions left to be answered
and i will break it all down right now
the latest chapter shows asta coming to
terms with the fact that he is now in a
completely different country on a
completely different continent extremely
far away from the clover kingdom asta is
of course concerned about not being able
to go back to his friends and help them
fight lucius but ryu assures him that
lucius is not going to make a move
anytime soon i have no idea how ryu
knows this but apparently he does and so
asta will have plenty of time for his
wano training arc ryu also explains that
being shogun makes him something like
the wizard king of hino country which is
obviously an extremely prestigious
position however asta is surprised by
the fact that he doesn't seem to sense
any magical power coming from ryu and as
a result ryu really doesn't seem very
strong ryu readily admits that he isn't
really that strong which surprises both
asta and pretty much every person who is
reading this chapter after learning that
this dude is yami's childhood friend and
the shogun of hino country who somehow
knows everything that happened to asta
and who also somehow knows how exactly
asta got there i think we all just
assumed that this guy has some insane
and completely broken magic you know
some sort of tie magic or psychic magic
or prophecy magic something along those
lines but it seems like this guy doesn't
actually have any magic much like hosta
or at least that's what we've been led
to believe but i don't know if i buy it
yet that said the girl we met earlier is
not impressed with asta's suggestion
that ryu is not strong and so she tells
this gaijin asta to watch his mouth when
speaking to the shogun the girl's name
is revealed to be ichika and it's clear
that she has a great amount of respect
for you even though he allegedly isn't
that strong asta can tell right away
from ichika's ki that she is very angry
at him and although her key kind of
feels familiar he also knows that he
shouldn't go anywhere near her she is
clearly very strong and she is not a fan
of asta so he senses that he should stay
away ryu tells asta that he must be
shocked to just randomly wake up in
another country so he says that he will
show us to around in order to put his
mind at ease now this could just be me
but to me personally it would be more
reassuring if he actually explained how
exactly asta got here but instead you
and ichika just take hosta on a casual
stroll through the hino country capital
which is basically edo era japan or
wanokuni from one piece now one very
interesting thing that asta does learn
during his casual stroll is that magic
inside this land is very different from
the magic of his own continent first up
they don't use grimoires here they use
scrolls second they don't call it magic
here they call it sorcery i mean okay
those are usually used as synonyms but
this little difference in wording did
get me wondering how is asta able to
communicate with ryu and ichika anyway
and how does he understand what everyone
else is saying out on the streets is it
really possible that the kingdom of hino
country just happens to speak the same
exact language as the people of the
clover kingdom and if so how in the
world did that come to pass i mean i get
it having everyone speak the same
language is a lot easier from the
perspective of the writer but it still
has to make sense so i do hope we're
gonna get some sort of explanation for
the complete lack of language barriers
asta quickly realizes that despite their
cultural and geographic differences the
people of hino country are essentially
similar to the people of the clover
kingdom and when he sees a woman walking
her child he is reminded of sister lily
and how she used to walk him and you
know back when they were orphans and
this also reminds him of the fact that
sister lily is currently in trouble and
needs his help which obviously gives us
to some very mixed feelings about being
stuck on another continent the section
of the city that astariu and ichika are
walking through is then suddenly
attacked by a group of bandits but even
though the attack was sudden and
unexpected ryu clearly sensed that it
was coming because he moved the woman
and child that asta saw earlier from the
very spot that the bandits ended up
destroying it seems clear that ryu has
some sort of powerful precognition magic
or i guess sorcery but for some reason
this ability does not register as a
magical power and i'm extremely
interested to find out why this is the
case could it be that it's really not
magic or sorcery but that his mastery of
ki is so advanced that he can somehow
read the future through ki and maybe
asta will also learn to use ki in this
way in a way that allows him to predict
what is about to happen which would of
course help him immensely in a fight
against someone who uses time magic now
that would be interesting as the bandits
attempt to wreak havoc in the city ryu
confirms once again that he has no
sorcery whatsoever and so he summons
ichika to take care of the bandits for
him the giant muscular banded leader
laughs at the idea that a slender girl
could pose a threat to him but in the
very next moment ichika unleashes an
incredible power that has never been
seen in black clover before the four
bandits are laid out instantly by what
appears to be a mixture of dark magic
and some sort of advanced key control in
fact asta noticed that the key in her
body swelled tenfold for a brief moment
as she attacked the bandits she's
basically using a magical kaoken attack
the cheering crowd then acknowledges her
as one of the seven ryuzen yamidono and
that is when we realized that yami
ichika is actually the younger sister of
yami sukehiro and what did i say in my
previous black clover video editor
please roll the tape
as always thank you guys so much for
watching
[Music]
and as the man is talking the girl
beside him seems to be like mean mugging
him as if she doesn't want him to joke
around about yami i wonder if she has
some connection to yami like maybe she
is his sister or something maybe she is
his sister or something maybe she is his
sister or something
anyway a shocked and impressed asta
casually approaches ichika but she
suddenly grabs his face and warns him
not to approach her the bones in asta's
face actually begin to crack under the
power of ichika's grip and for a
relatively young woman she definitely
has an extremely menacing aura i mean i
guess that's expected of yami's sister
but do you then explains that if fasta
wants to get stronger he has to be
trained by the seven and uzen which
includes ichika but ichika warns asta
that even though ryu seems to be looking
out for him she hates outsiders and men
like him so she is not at all too
pleased to be the one who has to train
him and on that insane note the reveal
of yami's badass and ominous little
sister this chapter comes to an end we
still don't know why or how asta was
teleported here or how you knew about it
and we also don't know how he knew about
what happened to asta before he was even
teleported if i had to guess i would say
that ryu has some sort of really
advanced key control that allows him to
anticipate future events and maybe even
read the key of others in order to
determine what they are thinking and
what they just experienced after all ki
is one of the most underexplored
concepts in black clover and it is a
concept that has been associated with
yami and hino country so it makes sense
that this concept would finally be fully
developed right now i look forward to
meeting the rest of the seven rusen and
to learning more about how key works if
i know my japanese and i definitely do
not ryuzen could mean peaceful dragon
although it could be translated to mean
a bunch of other things as well because
it is japanese but if the seven rusen
means the seven peaceful dragons then
this could hint at the fact that hino is
a fundamentally peaceful country and
their shogun ryu certainly seems like a
peaceful guy that said the fact that
there is a shogun also suggests that
there is also an emperor just like in
the clover kingdom power is shared
between the wizard king and the regular
king in japanese history the shogun was
a military leader who was appointed by
the emperor to protect japan however in
practice the shogun was often the one
with the real power and the emperor was
just a figurehead he know country might
function in a similar way but since liu
seems to be a man of peace it could also
be the opposite and so the one with the
real power and the militaristic mindset
could actually be the emperor so we
might even get a kaido type villain for
black clover's wano arc but we'll have
to wait and see definitely the most
interesting thing about this chapter is
the completely new ways that key is
being used and the implication is that
asta will also be able to unlock new
powers by mastering his key what do you
think that this new key power is going
to look like is it going to be like
advanced conquerors hockey in black
clover with key infused weapons and
attacks is it gonna be like koken attack
where sudden bursts of key power can be
applied for a limited amount of time is
it gonna be something else let me know
down below i'd love to get some awesome
theories going in the comment section if
you enjoyed this video and you to see
more in the future leave a quick like
and comment right now it helps me out a
lot and if you're new to the channel or
maybe you haven't taken the time to
subscribe yet do me a big favor and make
this the video that you subscribe and
hit that notification bell to turn on
all notifications you really have to go
through the trouble of subscribing
hitting the bell and then selecting that
option that says all if you don't do all
of those things you're still going to
miss a ton of our videos even if you are
subscribed it's just how youtube works
you can also hit me up on twitter and
instagram at animeopror big thank you to
all of our anime uproar patrons for
making videos like this one possible
special thank you to trucker tim a
disciple of lord twego himself and i
can't forget of our the one-tier patrons
including alpha sigma pate heffa the
toasted chi corey mcgowan own taylor and
anime s codem finally thank you to all
of our other patrons including pro hero
tier patrons the one and only gilgamesh
angel crews alicia octor fatboy games
kaido might be a duck alivania sandy and
the school bus if you enjoy our videos
and you feel that they provide value to
you consider supporting us on patreon or
by becoming a channel member as always
thank you guys so much for watching and
until next time see ya space cowboys